Expendables 3 all right let's talk about
that briefly fun making the movie I
would imagine you are getting to shoot
guns with people like Sylvester Stallone
that's got to be a dream come true yeah
doing scenes where you you and here
having battles that's good yeah I mean
my character is the essence of Barney
Ross his character so a lot of the
scenes and in the firefights and the
fights I we'd have him and I were
partnered together and you know I'm a
huge Rambo fan rocky fan and terminator
fan but we all grew up watching that get
exactly and so for me sometimes I forget
I was in character and I'd be shooting
guns looking sly Sara lines and then
like just smile and we're killing people
and sly would be like cook cook cook
code no smaller there's no 12 killer and
I just you lose yourself and I was up I
don't you understand what he was saying
I scream just coming out of his mouth he
was eating a sub Santa well then I'm
like yeah okay smiling even more cuz I
think thigh he's giving me props like
good job right no but it was fun you did
a very cool Vanity Fair photo shoot with
the entire cast this has got to be fun
the only problem is that's everybody in
the movie where I mean you're a you're a
big star what's going on here compared
to those guys I mean I'm just lucky to
be in the photo but for me were you as
supposed to be in the photo because
there look like you snuck in
truth be told I would I'd stand there
you know like in the placement everyone
else is drinking the coffee of the beers
for me I like even when we're shooting
there's three cameras on sly whenever
he's on the scene and then one on
everyone else so you know that the
cameras are always gonna be on sly so
I'm like I'll just position myself next
to sly and I if you see the camera or if
the camera can see you you can see the
camera or vice versa right and then I
just slowly inch forward lean in now
most small heads I want to get my head
you can tell in the photo that you are
pushing your head right above his
shoulder
it looks like he's automated I'm getting
in the he's a pirate and you're the
parrot that's good
[Applause]
you